So we continue the French Revolution
today and uh last class we looked at
Jeanjac Rouso and how he is the
philosopher poet of the revolution. He
provided the um dream okay for the
revolution. He told the French that
there was a promised land of reason
where if you use your reason, which is
God's gift to us, you could build a new
society, a utopia, a kingdom, a kingdom
on earth. In today's class, we will look
at Robespier, Maximian Robepier, who is
a prophet who will take his people into
the promised land. All right? So he is
the main instigator
uh the main leader of the French
Revolution. And um I'm going to make a
very strange argument today about Rose
Pier that no one has made before. So
it's going to be very controversial.
It's going to be very strange. So um I
will do this very slowly. Okay.
Basically, I'm gonna make the argument
to you that Rose Pier saw himself as the
second coming of
Jesus. And because he did
so, he sacrificed himself in order to
save the French Revolution. Okay? So,
that's my argument to you today. Again,
it's going to be a very controversial,
provocative argument. So, I will work
very slowly to explain it. All right.
Okay. So, let's go over some um let's
review some information we discussed
last class that's very important. Okay.
So, as we discussed last class,
traditionally in Europe, there have been
two major groups of people. Okay. There
there are the
peasants and the
poor and the slaves. Okay. So, basically
the lower class, the underclass. And
then at the top are the
nobility and
clergy. Now there's always been towns
people. There's always been merchants
and artisans and crafts people, but
they're in the minority. But because of
the gunpowder revolution, as Europe
begins to industrialize,
um these people are growing in number
and in influence and in power. Okay? And
we call these people today the middle
class.
And the middle class, it's an extremely
diverse
uh group of people. And you
can simplify the middle class into three
major categories. Okay? There's the
boujo. The bouro remember are the elite
of the town. So these are bankers,
lawyers,
doctors, factory owners,
um industrialists, merchants. Okay. So
they are the elite
of a
town. Then you
have what what we call later the
politariat. Okay. The polletariat um are
the lower class of a town. They include
artisans,
uh,
workers, okay? They're often the
majority. And then in between are what
we call the petite
boujo or the petty middle class. And
these are just people who are just stuck
in between these two major categories.
and they include um school
teachers, journalists,
um small lawyers, okay,
notaries, small business owners, okay?
So this is extremely diverse group of
people. Okay. Now and as we discussed
last
class, what often happens in revolution
is that is
that the Portuguese will often be the
become the counter elites. The counter
elites are just those who lead the
people to revolt against the
elites. The proletariat will be the
muscle or the
army. Okay? And the borso Z are in a
very unstable position because at first
they they will often support revolutions
because they want more political power
but over time they will uh become
reactionaries or they will try to
control the revolution or even kill the
revolution because the revolution is
threatening threatening their economic
interests. Okay. So this is the pattern
that we see in human history. Okay. So
um let's let's go over some terms that
we will need in order to understand the
French Revolution. Okay.
Um so what happens is
this. The middle class is growing in
France throughout the 17th and 18th
century. In fact, they become the main
economic
engine for France. At this time, France
is the most populous, the wealthiest
nation in all of Europe. But it is an
absolute monarchy. An absolute monarchy
is one in which the king makes all the
decisions. He decides whether or not to
go to war. He decides who has the power.
He decides who has to pay taxes. Okay,
he has absolute power. an absolute
monarchy. The absolute
monarchy leads France into a series of
disastrous wars in this in the 18th
century. The most prominent, the most
important is something called the Seven
Years War fought between France and
England primarily. There are other
participants as well. And this is a
world war. Okay, this is really the
first world war. You you can actually
call this world war zero. It's fought
all all around the world in North
America, in Europe, um in Asia. It's
fought everywhere. And France loses this
war. Okay? When you lose the war, you
incur a lot of debt. But not only that,
right after seven years war, France
sponsors the American
Revolution. Okay? So, France becomes the
main uh uh economic, political, and
military sponsor of the Americans in the
revolution against the British. And of
course, the Americans win this war when
the Americans refuse to pay back the
debt that they owe to the French. Okay,
so these are two major wars that are now
that have now left um France in very
dire economic straits. In fact, their
treasury, it's empty. Okay, the
government has no more money. Food
prices are um off the charts. People
don't have enough to eat. There's no
bread. the economies in
tatters. Okay. So what the king needs to
do now is he needs to
call an assembly of the people. Okay.
And this and this what's called the
estate general. The estate general. This
happens in the
year
1789. And this marks the beginning of
the French Revolution. And the purpose
for this estate general, it's very
simple. All the king wants to do is get
these people, the nobility, the clergy
and the middle class B to agree to give
them more money, okay? To pay more
taxes, to replenish the
treasury. Of
course, the middle class, everyone in
the middle class is like, "This is a bad
deal for us. We are the main economic
engine for France. We pay the most
taxes. We do the most work, but we have
no political power.
Therefore, we should have some political
power. In fact, we should check the
power of the king to uh declare war and
to raise taxes. Okay? So, they want a
constitutional
monarchy. No, at this time in history,
no one is saying that they should depose
a king and declare republic. No one is
saying that. Okay? All they want is a
more
um def a greater diffusion of power. All
right? Less power for the king, more
power for the people. That makes sense.
Okay? But of course, the king and the
elite don't really like this
idea. And the king um this is Louis the
16th and he's very indic
indecisive. Okay? He wants to maintain
the absolute monarchy but he lacks the
cutthroat mentality mentality that that
he would need to u
achieve um his power. Okay. So he should
have sent in the military to kill
everyone but he didn't want to do that.
He he goes back and forth. Okay. And so
what happens is now the estates general
breaks off. In the estate general there
are three estates. Okay. Three major
groups. There's the no the first estate
is called the clergy, the Catholic
Church. The second estate is the
nobility. The third estate is everyone
else, the commoners. Okay? So what
happens is the third estate breaks off
and they form something called the
national assembly. And they use national
assembly as a mechanism to press for
more rights. And the national assembly
because it's made up of most of the
members of the middle class. You have
different groups. of the politariat the
petite boujo the boujo
um they argue amongst themselves as
well. So what what's happening now is
that within the national assembly these
political groups political clubs are
forming in order to deise strategy and
to consolidate
um ideology amongst themselves. Okay.
And the most famous of these clubs is
are called the you guys remember the
jackabins, right? Have you guys studied
this
history? Okay. The jackabins. Oh,
anyway, the jackabins. The
jackabins. And this is just a meeting
place for um revolutionaries to come
together and discuss ideology. How do we
best proceed? Now, over time, as a
revolution
develops, the Jacobins will split off
into other groups. Okay. Um and the the
reason why they split off is because the
economic interests the political
economic social interests of these
different groups do not align with each
other. All right. So from the Jacobins
you will emerge the
fins. The fins represent the
boujoee. They don't want any economic
change. They want political change. They
don't want to um have a more equal
society. They just want more power over
the king. Okay. So these are
conservatives. But then you will also
emerge the Girundins. Girundins. The
Girundins are lower bouroi. These are
merchants. These are trades people. And
what they want is
war. They want France to declare war
against their enemies Austria, Prussia
basically. And and the reason why is if
there's war, they can make money off
war. Okay? Because these are merchants,
these are trades people. Um these are
industrialists. So they see war as an
opportunity to enrich themselves.
They're speculators basically. And these
are called the dironians. And then you
will also emerge the
cordelers. And the cordelers represent a
more extreme faction of the Jacobins who
want universal suffrage. They want the
polletariat to have more rights. Okay.
Um at this point the
polletariat is called the san
kulat. The s kulots. Okay. These are
very important people because they
provide the muscle for the revolution.
Sulot is French meaning without
breaches. So the custom at that time is
that if you are a middle class person
you wear like silk socks. Okay. But
they're expensive. So uh the middle the
lower class and polletitariat they they
don't they cannot afford these socks.
Therefore they're called the s kolat
okay the s
kulat and the colers want to galvanize
these people to create a full revolution
where the complete social economic
political and religious order is
overthrown. Okay. Then you have people
call the
herpertists and what they want to do is
overthrow the Catholic Church. Okay? So
throughout this revolution over time you
have different groups emerging with
different political interests within the
middle class. Okay? Does that make
sense? But at the same
time you have threats to the revolution.
Okay. So the main threat is the king
because a king he's a bourbon and his
brother his brother is king of Spain. He
has relatives all over Europe. So he
writes to Austria Prussia to ask for
aid. Can you come in send your army and
crush this revolution for me because my
army is not listening to me. Okay. So
the king is conspiring against the
revolution. There are these invasions
from Austria and Prussia. Okay. And then
England also sees the revolution as a
threat as well because remember every
nation has a middle class and they're
afraid that the middle class in their
nations will rise up against them as
well. So you have these external threats
coming in and then you also have
internal threats. Okay, you have
counterrevolutionaries, the nobility who
try to raise their own armies to crush
revolution. You also have economic
collapse going on. Okay. So, so the
revolution at this point in the year
1990, 1991, it seems threatened. So,
what happens is that someone
emerges from this chaos to lead the
revolution and his name is Maxmillian
Robespierre. Okay, Maxmillian
Robespier. and Ropes Pierre he is just a
provincial lawyer okay he is not from
Paris he is from Ara um a province in
France he's a lawyer and he's part of
the petite
boujo and he's not imposing he's not
huge he's he's not he's not powerful he
doesn't have a faction behind him and
he's not extremely charismatic he he he
he's almost like a
nerd but the thing about ropier is that
he is completely convinced vinced that
the
revolution must win and it will win if
he works hard enough. He works 18 hours
a day. The moment he gets up, he works.
He gives speeches. He he gives over 500
speeches in the National Assembly over
his career. Um he is extremely
virtuous. He's he he comes to Paris with
no money and he leaves Paris with no
money. his entire career as a lawyer
back in his hometown he spent defending
the poor and the weak against the
powerful and he has very clear ideas
about how to to proceed with the
revolution based on Jeanjac Rouso. Okay,
he sees himself as a disciple of Jeanjac
Rouso. Okay, remember last class we
looked at Rouso's ideas and and how to
implement um a kingdom of reason. Okay,
so
um Roses Pier because he is the most
virtuous, he is the most um he has the
most conviction, he becomes the de facto
leader of the revolution. Okay. uh he
becomes head of something called the
committee for public safety and it's not
a dictator it's not a dictatorship okay
he's not a dictator but he's head of a
comm committee that advises national
assembly on how to proceed and because
he he is the most forceful he has the
most ideas his ideas usually win
out okay and what and over time as he
accumulates more and more power he makes
more more radical proposals. His most
radical propo proposal is called the
reign of
terror. The reign of terror is a time of
mass mass execution. Okay. The
guillotine in
Paris to in order to sol solidify the
revolution in order to advance the the
revolution says we must instill terror
in our enemies.
We must investigate our enemies and
execute them if they are plotting with
the king against us. If they are
plotting with enemies against us. If
they are conspiring against us. If they
are engaged in economic speculation. If
they're hoarding food. These are all
enemies. They're trying to sabotage the
revolution. Therefore, we must kill
them. Okay. So over a few years, three
or four years, the ring of
terror will
kill at least 40,000 people within
terrorists alone. Okay, we don't know in
the provinces uh how how many people are
killed. The reign of terror will also
execute the king and
queen. So they will kill the king and
queen as well.
All
right. So, historians have been debating
for a long time if the ring of terror uh
was necessary because obvious obviously
it's a terrible thing to kill tens of
thousands of people for holding opposing
political opinions. Okay. And a lot of
these people were in fact just political
enemies of ropes
pier. Okay. So, how can we best
understand the ring of terror?
Well, if you think about it in this
class, we we've actually studied the
reign of terror before, okay? It's the
idea of human
sacrifice. And we've discussed this
before. Uh all societies engage in war
preodern times practice human sacrifice.
So, Romans did it, the Vik the Vikings
did it, the Aztecs did it. Okay? The
Aztecs were famous for for doing it. So,
why would you do human sacrifice if
you're engaged in war? Okay. Well, there
are different reasons and there are
three main reasons. The first reason is
you want to unify and energize the
people. Okay. When
people observe or they watch human
sacrifice, when they when they engage in
a spectacle, they become much more
excited. They be they have blood lust.
Okay? We call this blood lust, war lust.
They want to kill now. Okay? They got
they're excited to kill. Okay? That's
one purpose. Second purpose of course is
to
terrorize your enemy to put fear in your
enemy. Okay, that's obvious. And then
there's the third reason which is the
most important. The third reason is to
break
taboo. Okay, the break the
taboo. When you break a taboo, you are
signaling that you are crossing a
boundary. You've crossed a line and you
can never go back. You can no longer
compromise. You can only move forward.
Okay. So the taboo they broke in the
French revolution is they kill the king
and queen of
France. That meant that now all of
Europe would unite against the French
and they would come and exact a bloody
vengeance on the people of France. the
enemies of France, which include
England, the Netherlands, Prussia,
Austria, Russia, the five most powerful
nations in all of Europe, they would
they they will now come and they will
not stop until they have
avenged the the the dead king and queen.
Okay, they've because the French people
have broken this taboo and the monarchs
cannot
allow the French people to get to to get
away with this. Okay? Because if they
did, then this would encourage their
people to rise up against them as well.
Okay? So by with the ring of terror,
ropes breaks the taboo. And when you
break the taboo, then you are now all
in. You are fully committed to the
revolution. There's no more of
compromise. There's no more surrender.
There's no more uh going back into the
past. You are now in the promised land.
You are now in a new world. you must
fight to the death for this world. Okay,
does that make sense?
Okay, but what happens
next? Um, and it's very strange is
ropesier has accumulate all the power in
France. He's not dictator. He doesn't
have the powers to be a dictator, but
he's de facto dictator. And at this
point in his life, he's only like in his
mid-30s. He could choose to become king,
right? He could be like, you know what?
For the revolution to fully succeed, I
need to become the dictator. And the
people, the S colot love him. The wins
love him. He would win. Okay. But at
this particular stage in the revolution,
he
decides to just sit at home. He goes
into seclusion. He kind of gives up and
this allow this gives time for his
enemies to conspire against him and he
has a lot of enemies because this is
this is the ring of terror. Rose Pierre
is virtuous and no one can be as
virtuous as Robes Pierre and his enemies
think this guy is crazy. He's going to
kill
everyone who is not as virtuous as he is
and therefore we're all going to be
killed at some point. Okay. So they try
to they decide to act first. So the
national assembly conspire to vote for
his canon canonation. They vote for his
death and he does not resist. The most
he does is he goes to national assembly
and he gives a speech cursing them all.
Okay. And then but then afterwards they
send uh soldiers to arrest him and he
doesn't really resist and then he's sent
off to the guillotine and then he's
killed and that's the end of
Rosepier and this is a mystery a paradox
to historians like why did Rosier fall?
Why didn't he
resist? Why did he just give up?
Okay. All right. So to answer this
question, I'm going to provide you w
with a new idea. Okay? And this is a
hard idea. So please feel free to
challenge me or ask questions. Make sure
you're clear. Okay? All right. So the
thing you you need to understand is
this. In a time of revolution, when
people reject
authority, when people say, "I no longer
believe in God. I refuse to listen to my
priests." the nobility is evil. I refuse
to submit to the
king. The question then is what takes
charge? What guides society now? And the
answer is
mythologies. Mythologies are the
subconscious operating system of
society. Okay, does that make sense? So,
what mythology does everyone in France
know? Well, the story of Jesus, right?
What's the story of
Jesus?
Um,
Jesus is
persecuted for telling the truth, for
trying to bring about a more equal, more
just world. In fact, he is murdered.
He's crucified. Okay? It's
cru crucification. Okay? And the moment
he's crucified, people discover that
he's truly the son of
God. And then after he dies, he ascends
to
heaven where he wait he awaits a day
when he has to return. Okay? And he does
return in something called the second
coming. Second coming.
And the second coming, Jesus will become
the god of war. Okay? The Messiah. And
he will lead his people into victory
against the entire
world. And once he defeats the entire
world, he will build a kingdom of
heaven, a thousand years of peace. And
then after a thousand years of peace,
heaven will come onto earth. We will all
become immortal. And those who have been
good will live in heaven. those who have
been bad will burn in hell. Okay, the
final judgment. Okay, so that's a story,
a mythology that everyone understands,
that everyone knows in France. And so
even though the French Revolution was a
revolution of reason when they're trying
to reject the Christian faith, the
mythology is still implanted in their
brains. And this mythology becomes the
operating system of the French
Revolution.
Okay. So
um using this
mythology let's now ask
ourselves what happened when Rosepier
died. Okay three things happened when
Rosepier
died. The first one that happened
is Rosepier became a
scapegoat. Okay a scapegoat is someone
who takes the blame for all the crimes
of the community. So the ring of terror
is when the Parisians killed 40,000
people and some of them were innocent.
And when Rose Pier died, he took the
blame for the ring of terror, right?
They killed him because they call him a
tyrant. He's the one responsible for
those 40,000 deaths. And he said, "Sure,
I'll take the blame." Okay? He becomes a
scape. That's the first thing that
happens. Second thing that happens is he
becomes a martyr for the revolution. He
died in order to save the revolution.
Rose said to the people, "If you need me
to die in order to cleanse you of your
sins, then I will do so. And I will do
so because what matters is not my life
but the
revolution." Okay? He becomes a
martyr. And when he became a martyr,
what he did was he made people feel
guilty for having persecuted and killed
him. Okay? And so the third thing he
becomes is a role
model or a
paragon, a
hero. He's telling the French people,
listen, I could have become king. I had
all the power in the world, but I chose
to sacrifice myself because what
mattered most was the revolution.
If you feel guilty for having killed
me, then you have an obligation to the
revolution to sacrifice necessary in
order to save the revolution. Okay? So
this is what happened. The moment he
killed himself, he became a scapegoat, a
martyr and a paragon of virtue, a hero
to the
people. People will feel guilty for
having killed him. And now they will
transfer this guilt into promoting and
saving the revolution.
And so in other
words, the moment that he died, G
Rosepier became
Jesus. He became in the minds of the
French people second coming of Jesus.
Does that make
sense? Okay. So that's my argument to
you today. And so over the the rest of
the class we will look at the evidence
and actually the best evidence
is how Rose Pier died. Okay. So let's
compare the death of Jesus and the death
of Rose Pier and you will see they match
up. They line up perfectly. Okay.
So let's look at the death
of Jesus.
And then we'll look at Ruth Pier, his
death.
Jesus spends his life preaching the
truth to the people and trying to build
a more just and equal
world. But he knows that eventually he
must die in order to complete his
mission. Okay. So at the in the last
supper, he tells his followers, the
disciples, one of you will betray me.
Okay, betrayal. And of course, this
person's name is Julius Escariat who
betrays Jesus to the high priest of
Jerusalem. Okay, so the f so the first
thing is
betrayal. But after the dinner, everyone
goes to sleep and Jesus goes to a quiet
place. Okay. He isolates himself. Why?
Because he
knows that the soldiers are coming to
arrest him and to put him to death.
Okay? The servants of the high priest
are going to come and arrest
him. The servants do come to arrest
Jesus. And Jesus submits. Okay?
Submission. He does not resist.
But one of his disciples, Peter, he he
sees what's happening and he rushes to
try to save
Jesus. And uh Peter cuts off the ear of
one of the servants of the high priest.
And Jesus tells him, "No, no, no, Peter,
go home. This is what I must do by
myself. I must go with the with the high
to the high priest." Okay. He goes to
the high priest who then presents him to
the Roman governor, Pontius Pilate,
right? And Pilate says, "Jesus, you've
been accused of crimes against your
people of defying the laws of your God.
What do you have to say in your
defense?" And Jesus says, "Nothing."
Jesus does not defense defend himself.
Okay. Okay. So, submission. Okay. And
then Pon Pilot says, "Fine. If you
refuse to defend yourself, then I can
only condemn you to death." So Jesus um
there's he has to bear a cross, okay?
And he's bearing the cross. The Jews
line up and see him and they jeer him.
Okay? They curse him. They spit at him.
They throw stones at him. And all this
while there's someone, a soldier, a
centurion following him and whipping
him. Okay? This is called the
passion. Okay? He is punished. And then
he is of course crucified. And he's
crucified. It's the worst way to die,
right? People, thousands of people come
and watch him be get crucified and then
die. Okay, that's the story of Jesus.
Guess what
guys, this story
becomes the death of Rosepier too. So,
Ropier
is betrayed. He is betrayed by his
political allies and
friends. He helped these people amass
power and once they amass power and
Rosar gets rid of all the the other
enemies, they see Robier as the ultimate
threat so they conspire against him.
Okay, so it's a
betrayal. Respir is asked to speak to
the to the assembly. He does. Okay. But
he knows the assembly has already
condemned him to to death. There's no
point in him arguing. Okay. So what he
does is after his speech, he goes to a
building, a town hall, and he goes to
the second floor and he be and he is
isolated from everyone. Okay? He knows
his fate. He knows they're going to come
and kill him. And he just stands there.
His friends, his most loyal followers,
okay? Say to him,
"Wop, they're coming to kill you. Let's
rally the p people. Let's go to the
sections, the sulot. We have thousands,
tens of thousands of loyal followers.
Let's rally them. Let's inspire them to
revolt. Let's let's raise an army and
kill the entire national assembly. And
Robes Pier refuses. Okay. Then you have
the Paris Commune leaders from the Paris
Commune. They they they've heard what
happened to Roespier. So they sent a
delegation to the section and say, "Hey
guys, we need to defend our hero." Okay?
And so you have this huge crowd moving
towards the National Assembly and
they're waiting for Rose to appear
before them and said, "Fight, fight,
fight." Okay? Defend the revolution,
save the revolution, save Robes Pierre.
They're waiting for the hero to come out
and lead them. Robes Pier refuses to say
a word. He just he just sits there and
then begging begging Robes Pierre please
Roses Pierre we have to do something and
Robes Pierre just he stares off into
space. Okay. He's like Jesus at this
point. He knows his fate. He knows his
destiny. He refuses to fight his
destiny. He submits.
Okay.
Submission. The soldiers come and his
followers they get into a fight. Some
people die, but a soldier shoots a
pistol into the jaw of Rose Pier. Okay.
And now he's covered in blood and he's
trying to wipe off the blood, but he's
in pain. Okay. And even though he's in
pain, they still take him to the
guillotine. So the passion of Rosepier
and he's being driven on a horse with
his followers and there's about 100 of
them to the guillotine. They will be all
massacred at once. Okay. and thousand
people lining up on the streets to to
shout down the tyrant. Down the tyrant.
Okay, they hate Whoops Pier. These are
people who lost uh France family in the
ring of terror. So they want to see this
guy dead and ultimately
then ropes pier then is
guillotine and that's the end of ropes
pier. Okay, do you see how these stories
line up perfectly? It is almost as if
Robespier is trying to act out the story
of Jesus for the French people. That is
that is his
intention. That is his
legacy. He wants people to understand
that it was Jesus who appeared before
them. And Jesus made the ultimate
sacrifice because he loved his people in
order to rally his people to save the
revolution and fight off the enemies of
France.
Okay, these stories line up too well.
Now, we know
that this story is basically just
mythology. Okay, but I keep on telling
you guys in history for us humans,
mythology ideas are real.
Okay. So, Rose Pier remember this
mythology or subconsciously knows this
mythology and he acted out for the
French people in order to inspire
them in order to fully realize the
revolution.
Okay. So in other words, the French
Revolution was essentially a relig
religious
mythology in which ropes pier
volunteered to play the part of
Jesus,
right? To be Jesus, you need to make the
ultimate sacrifice. You need to
sacrifice yourself in front of people.
And that's what he did. Okay? And after
his death, people now see that he's
Jesus. And now people are inspired to
believe that there will be a second
coming of Ropes Pier. Someone will come
come who will be Ropes Pier and who will
lead them to final victory against all
their enemies. And this person's name
is
who? Who who comes after ropes
pier? Napoleon. Do you understand? So
Napoleon takes
advantage of all this mythology and he
uses it in order to become the king of
France. Okay, Rose refused to become
king but Napoleon will become king and
we'll discuss Napoleon next class and
this will end our French revolution
trilogy.
Okay. All right. So right so um this is
the main argument. Okay. So I provide
basically the basic story but what's
important for us is now to look at the
evidence. Okay. So we're going to look
at the speeches of ropes PR in a context
of French revolutionary history. All
right. To understand his
mentality. Right now, what's really
important is for us to understand his
psych psychology and ask ourselves if if
g if Wilspir really believed he was
Jesus or a
prophet, then do his speeches, do his
words actually provide evidence for
this. Okay? And I will show you that in
fact there is evidence that he does in
fact see himself as a
prophet. But before I start the
evidence, are you guys clear about this
argument? Are you clear about the story
I'm telling
you? All right. Are you guys clear? All
right. Good. So, let's look at the
evidence.
Sorry. All right.
Okay.
That is a great question. Does Roar know
that people will will know? He doesn't,
right? He can't know. And in fact, if
you look at the Bible, the Bible is very
clear. Jesus himself was full of doubt.
He was not completely uh sure that he
people will remember him. Okay. But
that's the problem of
faith. If you truly believe in the
people, you will have faith in the
people. You understand? So it was an act
of faith,
right? Rose never at any point said,
"Hey, I am the prophet. I need to
sacrifice myself in order to save the
revolution. Okay, he hints at that, but
he never really says it
outright. And so he himself is extremely
conflicted
person, right? There's a part of him
that is pulling him towards his destiny,
but there's also another part of him
that resists against against this. Okay,
do you understand? We humans are
extremely complicated. Robes was a human
being. Okay. Okay. Does that make sense?
He can never be confident that this will
work out in the end. But because he took
that that leap of faith, it radically
changed human history. Okay? Because
because because I believe, okay, and I
will argue this, if he actually didn't
do this, if he actually just became
king, right? If he seized the crown like
Napoleon did, the French Revolution
would have failed and we really wouldn't
remember the French Revolution and it
really wouldn't change the course of
human history. What I will show you next
class is because he did so because he
sacrificed himself. It allowed Napoleon
to defeat all of Europe. Okay? Without
spirit sacrifice, Napoleon could not
have become
Napoleon. All right? So, does that make
sense? No prophet ever truly believes
he's the prophet. There's always a part
of him that is doubtful, that is
skeptical. Okay? But he
persists nonetheless. And that what
makes him heroic. Okay? And this is true
for all
prophets. Does that make sense? All
right. French
revolution. Um, maximum ropes pier.
Okay. So, some basic biographical
details about ropes pier. Okay. He was
born in a town called Ara, which is a
province of France. And his family there
for um a few generations was Bour. They
were all lawyers. His grandfather was a
lawyer. His father was a lawyer. But um
his mother, Rob's mother died giving
birth to a younger brother. They all
they both both both died. Um and then
Robier's father left the family and died
a few years later in Belgium or
somewhere. Okay. So Robepier went from
Bour to Pat Boujo. His family is still
wealthy but not as wealthy as before. Uh
Roses Pierre be becomes at a very early
age. Okay, maybe seven or eight be he
becomes the man of the family. Okay.
He's responsible for taking care of of
his younger brother and his younger
sister. His grandparents are still
pretty wealthy. They send him to a
Jesuit school where he excels
academically. Okay. His ambition is
really to be Jean Jac Rouso. He wants to
be a philosopher. He wants to be like a
poet philosopher like Jeanjac Rouso. He
writes a lot. He dreams of a better
world. He's very idealistic. He becomes
a lawyer. And as a lawyer, as I
mentioned, he spends all his time
defending the poor and the weak. He's a
champion of the oppressed. Um the
estates general is um organized and he
goes and becomes a representative and as
I said over the next few years he rises
to the very top. So the question we're
looking at today is how did Robes Pier
fall? Okay. So
um as I mentioned um before the states
general is
called France is in a is facing economic
financial collapse and so king Louis the
16th appoints Jack Neker to become the
finance minister. The thing about Neker
is that he understands that listen if
you people if you want people to pay
more taxes you need to give them more
political
representation. Okay. So Neker becomes a
champion of the middle class and he's
worshiped by the middle class. Louis the
16th doesn't really like what he has to
say and so they have this back and forth
for many years where Louis 16 fires him,
the people revolt, Louis the 16th hires
him back then fires him again. Okay, so
this goes on for quite some time. Neker
will also become um
um
okay around this time as the state
general is being called in order to
raise more taxes from the people the sea
who's who's a clergman he writes a very
influential pamphlet called what is the
third estate right because the first
second and third estates are being
called the first and second estates have
all the power the third estate has no
power so he writes a very influential
pamphlet
um asking the question, what is the
third estate? And he answer and his
answer is everything. Okay, the third
estate is everyone in France 99
99.99%. What has it been until now in
the political order? Nothing. What does
it demand to be? Something. Okay. So
during this time, pamphlets are like the
internet of today. It's how most people
get their news. And the pamphlets become
extremely
um violent and ext and call for radical
change. May 5th 1789 the three estates
meet. King Louis the 16th refuses to
acknowledge the third estate. He he
refuses to meet with them. He refuses to
heed their demands. So what happens is
the third estate form their own national
assembly. Okay? And these people are
radical. This is everyone in the middle
class. The boujo, the petite boros, the
sulot. They want more political power.
They want more political representation
in
government. Um while this is happening,
people's mood is becoming more and more
radical and violent. Okay? So the people
perish, they don't have any bread.
They're hungry. They're unemployed. They
feel hopeless. They feel the king is
aloof. So a group of people they storm
the bastau. The storming of the bastau
happens on July 14th 1789. This is
important because the national day of
France today is July 14th. Why? Because
on July 14th the people rose up and
stormed the fortress of the pastel in
order to get gunpowder in order to have
their own army. Okay? But not only that,
but they kill the governor of the pastel
and parade his head in front of
everyone. Okay? So people's mood is
extremely
violent and this violence is happening
all around France. It's been decades of
economic stagnation, poverty, military
defeat. People want a revolution.
um August 27, 1789, the National
Assembly declares the um a new
constitution. Okay, this new
constitution is something called the
Declaration of the Rights of Man and the
citizen and it becomes a basis for most
constitutions in the
world. Okay, this marks the beginning of
a new age in human history.
So let's look at a few passages from the
declaration of
rights of
men. For these reasons, the National
Assembly do recognize and declare in the
presence of the supreme being. The
supreme being is a god of reason and
with the hope of his blessing and favor
the following sacred rights of man and
of citizens. Okay? Do you understand?
These rights were not given to you by
the government. They were given to you
by God and these rights can never be
taken away from you. Okay. First, men
are born and always continue free and
equal in respect of their rights. Civil
distinctions therefore can be found only
on public utility. Okay, this is a
radical statement. Everyone is equal in
the eyes of God and therefore in the
eyes of the law. If there's nobility, if
there's a clergy, it's only because we
agree to give them this this distinction
based on their uh utility. Okay? Based
on the fact that they do public good for
us. Right? So that's a radical
statement. Second, the end of all
political associations is the
preservation of the natural and
imprescriptible rights of man. And these
rights are liberty, property, security
and resistance of oppression. Okay,
these are the fundamental human rights.
All government, all laws, all society
must be based on these fundamental
principles. Liberty, property, security
and oppression
uh resistance of of oppression. Okay.
Third, the nation is essentially the
source of all sovereignty. Nor can any
individual or any body of man be
entitled to any authority which is not
expressly derived from it. So what this
is saying is now is now we have a new
god. It's a nation state. France becomes
a first nation state and all authority
derives from the idea of the nation.
Okay? And no power can supersede the
power of the nation. Okay? Does that
make sense guys? Okay. Okay, this is the
beginning of modernity,
right? Four, political liberty consists
on the power of doing whatever does not
injure another. You can do whatever you
want as long as you don't harm someone
else. The exercise of the natural rights
of every man has no other limits than
those which are necessary to secure to
every other man the free exercise of the
same rights. And these limits are
determined only by the law. Five, the
law ought to prohibit only actions
hurtful society. What is not prohibited
by the law should not be hindered nor
should anyone be compelled to that which
the law does not require. Okay, so this
is a new idea of freedom, negative
freedom. Okay, before was positive
freedom where you had to do certain
things to become a citizen. Now it's
like if you're a citizen, you can do you
can do whatever you want as long as you
are not hurting someone else and you're
not breaking the law. Okay? And so this
is the where the modern or our modern
idea of freedom comes from. All right.
Six. The law is an expression of the
will of the community. All citizens have
a right to concur either personally or
by the representatives in its formation.
It should be the same to all whether it
protects or punishes and all being equal
in its sight are equally eligible to all
honors, places and employments according
to different abilities without any other
distinction than not created by their
virtues and
talents. Not only is the government now
responsive to the needs and demands of
the people, the people can at any time
become the government. Okay, so the
people are above the government. Okay.
So the hierarchy now is at the very
top is the nation and then below the
nation now is the people, right? And
then below the people now is the
government. The government only exists
in order to protect the rights of the
people. So the government only exists at
the
behest and
um concurrence of the people. All right.
Number 10. No man ought to be molested
on account of his opinions, not even on
account of his religious opinions,
provided has a vow of them does not
disturb the public order established by
law. Okay, so this is now the separation
of church and state. You are free to
believe whatever you want. 11. The
unrestrained communication of thoughts
and opinions being one of the most
precious rights of man, every citizen
may speak, write and publish freely
provided he is responsible for the abuse
of this liberty in case determined by
law. You are free to say whatever you
want. Okay. This is the freedom of
expression. Okay. So the declaration of
rights of man basically defines the new
liberal order.
Okay. Last is 17. The right to property
being invaluable and sacred, no one
ought to be deprived of it except in
case of evident public necessity,
legally ascertained and on condition of
a previous just indemnity. Okay. So
property is also a sacred right. If you
have property, it is yours by the will
of
God. Obviously, Ropes Pier does not like
this idea. Okay. So Rosepier gives a
speech arguing against this idea and he
proposes an amendment to this
idea. Now last session this is Rosepier
speaking before the national assembly.
Okay. Now last session I took the floor
in order to make a few important
additions to the declaration of the
rights of man and of the citizen. It was
my intention to expand your declarations
of the theory of property by the
addition of a few articles. Let the word
property threaten no
one. Filthy souls who value only your
money. I will not violate your treasures
even though I know how unclean the
source from which they are from which
they come. Okay. So most of you are
saying to everyone, I know you guys are
rich and you all want to protect your
property. I won't take away your
property. But please remember every one
of you stole this from someone else.
This is how you became rich. Through
theft, through crimes. Okay. So, Rosier
has a contempt for the
wealthy. Ask any one of these traders in
human flesh, what is property. Okay. How
do people people money for the slave
trade? Basically, he will show you the
long coffin called a ship in which men
are packed together and chained. Men who
seem yet alive. And he will tell you,
"Look at my property. I have bought it
head forhead." It it's a known fact that
at this time in history a lot of people
are getting rich off the slave trade.
Okay. Question this noble man who has
goods and subjects and who believes that
the world will can come to an end now
that he no longer possesses them and he
will expound similar ideas on property
to you. Okay. Rich people love their
land. They love their wealth. Question
the members of the Capatian dynasty and
they will tell you that the most sacred
property is the right of inheritance.
that they have the ancient right of
oppression, the 25 million Persians now
populating the territory of France, of
destroying them, of treating them
legally and monarchally according to
their own world will. So what most are
saying is that property cannot be a
secret right because property requires
the oppression of others, right? How do
you make your money how do you make
money off land? By getting people to
farm them, right? You're oppressing
people. you're explaining people.
Therefore, this is a contradiction. If
you're
saying
that property is sacred right, then
you're saying that God gave people this
right. But God would never give you the
power to oppress others. That makes no
sense. You have increased the number of
articles in order to afford the largest
possible latitude, the right to one's
property. And yet you have not added a
word in limitation of this right with
the result that the declaration might
make the impression of having been
credit not for the poor but for the rich
the speculators for the stock exchange
strawber to remedies the effects I
propose the following additions okay so
he's saying at this point in the
revolution the middle the entire middle
class including the boujo z are
participating in this revolution but
he's also saying that you the boujo have
written this constitution for your
benefit and not for the benefit of
everyone for the
people. Okay. So, we need to make
changes. First, property is that right
held by each citizen to dispose freely
of that portion of the general goods
guaranteed him by the laws. So, it's
society that gives people property, not
God who gives people property. Okay?
There's a difference. Second, the right
to property, like all other rights, is
limited by the obligation to regard the
rights of
others. All right? So when you speak you
you can do whatever you want as long as
you don't you don't harm others. Well he
what ro is saying is like that should
also apply to property. You can own
property as long as you are doing so in
a way that does not exploit
others. And the third is property may
not cause any detriment to our security
or to our liberty or our existence or to
the property of our neighbor.
Okay. Owning property should also not
harm the national interest as well. So
he's putting severe limitations on the
idea of property because what world
wants a society based on equality of
all.
Okay. Now um as this revolution is
happening
um there's a man named Joseph Ignets
Guilloton who will create something
called the guillotine. Okay, he's a
doctor and he wants to create a more
humane way of executing people. The
guillotine will become the main
mechanism of terror during the French
revolution. Right? So if you are an
enemy of the state, they will guillotine
you.
Um, as all this is happening, the king
is trying to work with the National
Assembly, but the king is also
conspiring against the National Assembly
by trying to write to his family and
friends overseas to raise armies against
the revolution.
And
um on June 20 to 21, 1792, the king and
queen actually try to flee France, but
they're recognized and they're captured
and sent back to uh
Paris. A month later, August 10th, the
people actually storm the king's
residence and um basically
massacre his Swiss guard, the
mercenaries who are paid to protect him.
Okay, finally they decide to just kill
this guy because he's been he's he's
threatening the revolution. Okay, King
Louise is always trying to conspire
against revolution. So they break this
taboo. Okay, because remember many
people many people believe that the king
is a son of God and they kill him. Okay.
And Rose Pier is explaining why and it's
very simple. Okay. Louie may die in
order that the revolution may live. It's
that simple.
What matters first and foremost is a
revolution. In order to advance a
revolution, everyone is expandable
including Rose Pier. Okay? Rose Pear is
only the prophet of revolution. He is
not the revolution it
itself. Um as is happening there is now
counterrevolutionaries. So in the Vendai
which is in West uh France peasants are
rebelling against the French revolution.
Why? because French French revolution is
calling for a secular state. It's
calling for a negation of religion and
um the thing about peasants is they love
their religion. Okay, so the peasants
are now rising up against the French
Revolution and it is a brutal war of
genocide. Okay, there are massacres and
atrocities on both
sides. Um on May uh 31st, Rose Pier
takes command of the National Assembly.
This is something called the Mont Tonaku
because he's in charge of of a faction
called the the mountain. Okay, this is
French for
mountain. And of course, he then begins
the ring of terror. Okay, and we
discussed why he starts the ring of
terror. He needs to unite the energies
of people to commit them fully to the
revolution. Okay, we can't go back.
There's no coming back after this ring
of terror. We have too many enemies now.
Um the thing about the
um ring of terror is he doesn't he kills
his
enemies but more
importantly he's also killing his
political allies. Okay the people on the
left he's also killing as well because
they also threaten the revolution. So
this is George uh Denton and he's one of
the leaders of the Cordelers which as as
I mentioned is a very leftwing political
group calling for the uh for universal
suffrage for property rights for the S
colot and he he's seen as a threat to
the revolution and
like ropier he's also fanatical he's a
fanatical prophet so the national
assembly votes to condemn him to death
and he says I have said and I have shall
I'll repeat. My home will soon be in
oblivion and my name in a pantheon. Here
is my head. It will I will it will
answer for everything. My life is a
burden to me. I shall be glad to be rid
of it. Okay. He's like screw you all. I
don't care. I have done God's work. If I
must rest, I shall rest. Okay. And then
he's
guillotine. Um Jacques Herbert is leader
of the herpetus. He's a journalist and
he's calling for the complete
abolishment of the Catholic Church. And
of course the peasants don't like that.
The the peasants would all unite against
you. So he's seen as a threat to the
revolution even though he is a close
ally of Rose Pier and Rosepier also has
him killed. Okay. So Rosier is not just
killing his enemies but he's also
killing his friends as well. And it's
all in order to advance the revolution.
Um so now Rose Pier needs to explain why
this is happening. Okay. And he presents
a vision of the revolution which tells
us that he sees himself as a prophet.
He's trying to build a new world. It's
it it right now there's a war between
good and evil and good must triumph no
matter what the cost. All right. So his
speech before the national assembly to
explain the ring of terror to judge by
the power and the will of a republican
soldiers it will be easy to defeat the
English and the traitors but we have
another task of no less importance but
unfortunately of greater difficulty.
This task is a task of frustrating but
an
uninterrupted access of energy. Okay. So
the ring of terror is to energize the
people, right? The eternal intrigues of
all enemies of freedom within the
country of paving the way for the
victory of the principles on which the
general well depends. Okay? So our true
enemies are not the English, the
Austrians, the Prussians. Our true
enemies are those traders within us.
They're the ones who most threaten this
the
revolution. This is another speech.
Okay. What's the goal toward which we
are heading? Why are we doing this? Why
the ring of terror? The peaceful
enjoyment of liberty and
equality. Kingdom of kingdom on earth.
Utopia. Paradise. Okay. Justice and
equality. The ring of that eternal
justice who laws have been inscribed not
in marble and stone but in the hearts of
all men. even in that of the slave who
forgets them and in that of the tyrant
who denies them. Okay, this law, this
justice, this equality is what God
promised us because it's implanted in
our hearts. We all yearn for this world
when we are all equal, when justice
prevails. Okay? We are fighting for the
freedom and liberation of of all
humanity from oppression. That's why
we're fighting. We seek an order of
things in which all the base and cruel
passions are in chain. Okay. So last
class we discussed John Rouso and
remember John Rouso his most famous line
is we are born free but we are all in
chains. Okay. So this is a rewriting of
that idea. So what keeps us in in us in
chains are
emotions. So we want a world in which
our reason prevails and we are control
of our emotions. Then we'll be truly
liberated.
All the beneficent and generous passions
are awakened by the laws where ambition
becomes the desire to merit glory and to
serve our country. Okay. So your
ambition is not to gain wealth at the
expense of others. Your ambition is to
help the community grow and and thrive.
Where distinctions are born only of
equality itself. Where the citizen is
subject to the magistrate, the
magistrate to the people and the people
to justice. Where our country assures
the well-being of each individual and
where each individual proudly enjoys our
country's prosperity and glory. where
every soul grows greater through the
continual flow of republican sentiments
and by the need of deserving the esteem
of a great people where the arts are the
adornance adornments of the liberty
which enobles them and commerce the
source of public wealth rather than
solely the monstrous opulence of a few
families guys he's talking about
communism okay a world in which everyone
is equal everyone is free to do what he
or she wants and this will lead to the
general prosper purity, wealth and
happiness of the entire nation. Okay.
So, Rose Pier is dreaming of a world in
which everyone is
equal. The great purity of the French
revolution's fundamental elements, the
very solity of its objective is
processing what creates our strength and
our
weakness. Our idealism is what gives us
power. Okay? Our strength because it
gives us the victory of truth over
deception and the rights of public
interest over private interests. Our
weakness because it rallies against us
all men who are vicious. All those who
in their hearts plan to desoil the
people and all those who have desoiled
them in what impunity and those who
reject liberty as a personal calamity
and those who have embraced the
revolution as a livelihood and the
republic as it were an object of prey.
Okay. So we are fighting a war of good
versus evil. Among us are men of good
who want to build a better world who
care for others. But there are also
speculators among us who use
the who use the revolution in order to
advance his or her interest. Okay?
That's why we're fighting this war.
We're trying to rid the world of those
who seek to
exploit others, who pray on
others, okay? Who enjoy being
bad. That's why we're fighting this
war. Hence the affection of so many
ambitious or greedy men who since the
beginning have abandoned us along the
way because they had not begun the
voyage in order to reach the same goal.
Okay. One could say that the two
contrary geniuses that have been
depicted competing for control of the
realm of nature are fighting in this
great epoch of human history to shape
irrefibly the destiny of the world and
that France is a theater of this mighty
struggle. Okay, this is the end of the
world. This is the end of the world.
This is good versus evil. Good must
triumph. It must. So every sacrifice
must be made. Without all the tyrants
encircle you within all the friends of
ty conspire. They will conspire until
crime has been robbed of hope. We must
smother the internal and external
enemies of the republic or parish in
this situation. The first maximum of
your policy ought to be to lead the
people by reason and the people's enemy
by terror. Okay. This reign of terror.
It is
about the ultimate victory against evil.
We are killing our enemies because our
enemies destroy want to destroy all good
in the
world. If the main spring of popular
government in peace time is virtue amid
revolution, it is at the same time
virtue and terror. Virtue without which
terror is fatal, terror without which
virtue is impotent. Terror is nothing
but prompt, severe, inflexible justice.
It is therefore an emanation of
virtue. It is less a special principle
than a consequence of a general
principle of democracy applied to our
country's most pressing
needs. We have to be as brutal as our as
enemies if we are truly to promote
democracy. And there's no there's no
other
choice. All right. So the ring of terror
is just one policy that rotier adopts in
order to save the revolution. But he
also adopts a new religion called the
festival the call of the supreme being.
Okay. This is a new religion where god
is the god of reason. All right. So
rophere is adopting a lot of different
policies and again he is working
selflessly in order to promote the
revolution. But eventually he gets
exhausted. Okay. He just breaks down. He
has he has a nervous breakdown because
it's too hard. Like he wants people to
be virtuous. He wants people to be
reasonable. And everywhere he sees like
he sees everyone in front of him and
everyone's in everyone's plotting
against him. Everyone's trying to
exploit the revolution for his or her
own benefit. Okay. And
eventually Rosepur is brought down and
he is guillotine. Okay.
But let us look at his last speech to
fully understand how he sees the
revolution and his own death. Okay, this
is his last speech before the National
Assembly. This is two days before he is
to be executed. Okay, this is July 26,
1794. The enemies of the republic called
me tyrant. Okay, the the National
Assembly is now calling for his
execution because he's a
tyrant. I were I such they would gravel
at my feet. I would gorge them with
gold. I should grant them impunity for
their crimes and they would be grateful.
Right? If I'm a tyrant, then I would
make political alliances. I would bribe
people. I would benefit people. But I
don't do that. I incorruptible. I'm
virtuous. Were such the kings we have
vanquished far from denouncing ropier
would lend me their guilty support.
Okay. So the kings of England,
Netherlands, Austria, Prussia, Russia
are all aligned against the French
Revolution. Why? Because they're afraid
of revolution at home. Right? So ropes
are saying, "Listen, if I if I just
become a king, they would marry their
daughter to me and we all be one big
happy family." Okay? They would not they
would not see me as a threat.
There would be a covenant between them
and me. Tyrony must have tools. But the
enemies of tyranny, whether does their
path tend to the tomb and to
immortality, what tyrant is my
protector? To what faction do I belong?
Yourselves. Everything I've done is for
the people of France. And you know
this since the beginning of the
revolution has crushed and annied so
many detected traders. You the people
our principles are that faction a
faction to which I am devoted and
against which all the scoundrelism of
the day is banded. Okay. It is because I
Wilia and the and the only virtuous
person who has fought for the
revolution. Now do you conspire against
me? The confirmation of the republic has
been my object and I know that the
republic can be established only on the
internal basis of morality. Okay. it.
Only if we are virtuous can we win out
in the end against evil. Against me,
against those who hold kindred
principles, the league is formed. My
life, oh my life, I abandon without a
regret. I have seen the past. I foresee
the future. I am the
prophet. I have seen the past and I
foresee the future. You will kill me. I
accept my
fate. What friend of his country would
wish to survive the moment when he could
no longer serve it? when he could no
longer defend innocence against
oppression. You have taken away my
powers. Fine. Take away my life as well.
Because I serve, I live only to
serve. Wherefore should I continue in an
order of things? Where intrigue
eternally triumphs over truth? Where
justice is mocked, where passions the
most object or fears the most absurd
over the sacred interests of humanity.
The pollution has so the revolution has
been polluted. It is is now corrupt. If
it if you take my life, I I'll be glad
to give it to
you. Question history and learn how all
the defenders of liberty in all times
have been overwhelmed by calamity. Okay.
All prophets in their time were
prosecuted including Jesus and Socrates.
But their producers died also. The good
and the bad disappear alike from the
earth but in very different conditions.
Oh Frenchmen, oh my countrymen, let not
your enemies with their desolating
doctrines degrade your souls and
innovate your virtues. Now is the time
to stand up and fight for the
revolution. I may die, but the
revolution must live. Death is not an
internal sleep. Citizens if face the
tomb that
motto graven byious hands which spreads
over all nature a funeral crepe takes
from oppressed innocence its support and
affronts the beneficent disposition of
death. Inscribe rather therefore these
words. Death is the commencement of
immortality. I leave to the oppressures
of the people a terrible testament which
I proclaim with the independence
befetting one whose career is so nearly
ended. It is the awful truth. Thou shalt
die. Yes, today I die but so will you.
And when we all die, we must face our
maker. We must all see God and we must
account for our lives. I go to
God in full conscious. I'm happy to go
directly to God and await my fate. Okay?
And these are his last words. Why should
I where should live under system where
intrigue triumphs over truth where
justice is a lie where the basis
passions and the most ridiculous of
terrors supersede in man's heart the
most sacred duties. Why should I regret
to escape from the eternal torture of
seeing this horrible secession of
traitors who by concealing the turpitude
of their souls under the veil of virtue
and even of friendship will leave
prosperity in doubt which was the
greater their cowardice or their crimes.
You members of the national assembly
were elected to serve the people. You
have only served yourself. You have only
fought for your own economic interests.
And because you see me as a threat, you
see Rose Pierre as a man of purity, of
virtue, of reason. You conspire against
me. And I am happy to be condemned to
death because it will it will liberate
me from this evil world that you have
created. But upon my death, there shall
come
vengeance.
Okay? So that's it guys. That's Rob's
pier. All right.
So, does does this make
sense? Okay. He sees himself as a
prophet who must save the
revolution. At first, he believes that
he must kill his enemies, the enemies of
the revolution in order to save the
revolution. But then he recognizes that
no no no this ring of terror is not
really about energizing the people. It's
really about
eliminating the
enemies of his allies. Okay? It's really
about political intrigue. And so he
recognizes that if this revolution is to
really triumph then he must make the
ultimate sacrifice. Rather than try to
cease the crown, he must give his life
for the revolution to set an example for
everyone, especially the oppressed and
the weak. And after he
dies, this will energize France. It will
unite France. It becomes a hurricane.
Okay? The French revolution now becomes
a hurricane. All right? And Napoleon
will come. He will take this hurricane
and he will unleash it on the entire
world and he will conquer the entire
world. And that's what we'll do in the
next class. Okay? We'll look at
Napoleon. But does this make sense to
you
guys? Any
questions? Yeah. Go.
So how do you know about
Okay. Okay. So um the question
is are people conscious of what Rose is
doing? And I I I know this is a hard
argument. Um and I I I know this is hard
to understand, but this is all happening
subconsciously. Okay, this is all
happening without people being
aware of it. Rosephere is not aware of
it. The people are not aware of it.
Okay, so the argument goes like this.
First of
all,
mythology is the collective
subconscious.
Okay, mythology is a collective
subconscious. That that's the first
idea. Okay, does that make sense to you?
Okay, second idea is
this. When
authority breaks
down, the
mythology takes
over. Okay, do you understand? Okay, the
arament is this. Usually someone in
authority orders people around, right?
Someone in authority, whether it's a
general or a priest or a teacher, tells
you what to do. But when you deny this
authority, when you reject this
authority, what tells you what to do?
Well, mythology. Okay, your collective
subconscious. Okay, you are guided by
your collective subconscious even though
you don't know it.
Right. The third argument is that
mythology is essentially a
play. Okay. A mythology is a play. It's
a
story.
And this play requires
actors. Okay. So the
leaders become now the actors.
this play must take place because that's
what people want. Now you need actors.
You need volunteers to come and be the
actors in this play. So whoever choose
who whoever volunteers now must play
that role and then people will follow
that person. Okay? So Rose Pierre played
the role role of Jesus. So people
followed him even though people don't
really know why they're following him.
Okay? Does that make sense? But they're
following him because he's willing to
play the role that's required of him in
this play that's being acted out during
the French
Revolution.
Okay? But, and this is really
important, this play only
works if people play the role they're
supposed to play. When they speak the
lines they're supposed to speak, right?
That's really important because what
happens is if people break the role and
instead of people listen I was just
acting the entire play
dies. Okay, the play dies. Why is this
important? Because next class we will
look at Napoleon. Okay, in the beginning
the Napoleon is playing his role, right?
He's the Messiah come to earth to lead
the French people to final victory
against evil to unite the world in good.
He's playing that role. But then he does
something that he should not do and
which breaks the play and which is what
you guys do you guys know what does do
that roast doesn't
do? That's right. He declares himself
emperor and you're not supposed to do
that. Okay. If you're roastier you would
never declare yourself emperor. You can
make yourself first citizen. You can
make yourself counsel, dictator,
whatever, but you cannot make yourself
emperor because now you're like everyone
else, right? And when he does that, this
is very important, he destroys the
French Revolution. And after that,
France is now destroyed by their
enemies. Napoleon
falls.
Okay? Does that make sense
guys? So only if you are playing your
role can this play work out. Once this
play works out, people are energized to
sacrifice their
lives. Okay. The reason why Napoleon at
first could defeat all his enemies is
his soldiers were not afraid to die.
Okay? They didn't care. They're like,
"Well, you know, if we die, we're going
to heaven." That that's what World War
did. Okay? But we'll discuss this next
class. Okay. Does that make sense? So,
so it's a hard argument to make because
like I'm I'm arguing like there is a
subconscious operating system to society
that we don't ever see, okay, that we
don't we don't ever talk about. But once
we see this, okay, then it helps us
explain the world we live
in. It explains a lot of history to us.
But you need to be able to see it first.
And most people don't see it. Okay, if
you look at the traditional accounts of
the French Revolution, it's always these
economic, political, structural forces.
Okay, I'm presenting a different idea
here. Okay, does that make sense? Great.
Any any any other questions?
Terror is kind of human and it is
a way to
No, no. Um, the reign of terror was a
form of human sacrifice, okay? They
literally took their enemies and they
killed them in front of everyone, right?
And that's no different from the Aztecs,
no different from the Vikings, no
different from the Romans. Okay? These
are all societies that practice human
sacrifice in order to unite the people,
right? To galvanize the people, energize
them, create blood lust, to terrorize
their enemies, and to break taboo, to
tell to send a message that we will
never go back.
We are going towards total victory. We
won't surrender. We won't compromise.
Okay? It has nothing to do with Jesus.
In fact, Jesus, the story of Jesus is to
tell us we no longer need human
sacrifice because Jesus made the
ultimate sacrifice.
Okay? Does that make sense? Okay. But um
but the ring of terror, what it did was
unleash all this energy. Okay. Okay. And
this energy, it's polluted energy
because it's it's it's it's based on
violence, on vengeance, on hatred.
Right. So what Voltfeir decides to do,
and it's very clever of him, he needs to
now to purify this energy. Right? And
how do you purify this energy? By
becoming a scapegoat. By sacrificing
yourself by telling the French people
the ring of terror was not your fault,
it was my fault. Blame me. Sacrifice me.
Okay. For what happened? I will take the
guilt of the
nation. I will cleanse cleanse you of
your sins so that you may move on. Okay,
does that does that make sense? Okay,
good. Any more questions? Great
questions,
guys. Okay. All right. So, this ends
part two of the French Revolution. Next
class on Tuesday is Napoleon and this
will end the French Revolution trilogy.
Okay.